[Music]
the mission of the computer vision
platform is to enable our partners to
implement the next generation Enterprise
CI solutions and these focus on the
enterprise has led in the last few years
to significant breakthroughs of
application of AI across multiple
verticals industries are using our
technology to detect damage in their
facilities for predictive maintenance
min entertainment companies are using
our technology to implement intelligent
content management systems and the focus
of this talk healthcare organizations
and laughs are using our technology to
analyze medical imagery to optimize
radiology and pathology workflows so a
few examples of this the brain team has
been using computer vision to detect
diabetic retinopathy leveraging fundus
images or images from the back of the
eye now this is critical work and a
significant breakthrough because
diabetic retinopathy is one of the
leading and fastest-growing causes for
for blindness if this is not being
detected on time it can lead to
irreversible blindness now the bad news
is that there's not that many physicians
in the world that can detect this
disease on time so it's very critical
for us to empower these doctors with AI
technology so that we can prevent
blindness and this is especially true in
underserved populations where there's
not enough coverage of doctors another
example is a work from our brain team
who has been using computer vision
algorithms on top of t-shirts lights to
take different forms of cancer this is
also very critical work because
detecting cancer any sort of slides can
take multiple hours from physicians and
requires multiple years of training and
to explain why one single slide because
it's mostly large and impasse over one
gigapixel of resolution
this is also very critical for us to
help those doctors detect and analyze
these images to improve different
patient outcomes now these two use cases
can be implemented with our computer
vision tuning today which to recap is
comprised of two sets of products are
pre-trained products from the vision API
and our customizable products call or
m/l vision our pre dream products
require no training they're completely
plug and play into your code you can
just simply issue a tresco to be able to
get predictions from your data these are
great for generic and well understood
use cases and our or ml vision products
can be customized for your own data uses
behind the scenes will say oh there are
neural architecture search and hybrid
parameter tuning technology this is
great for more specialized use cases now
last year we introduced our ml vision
for image specification and we're very
humbled by the popularity and success of
this tool but we know that this is only
part of the toolkit required to do
computer vision especially as we talk
about more complex healthcare SN areas
so the reason I'm very excited to
announce our ml vision object detection
this product allows you to detect not
only the presence but the location body
box coordinates of objects in your
images and this whole experience is is
very seamless and it has the same model
quality as the rest of the our ml
product family and to explain how to use
this technology in a real use case I'm
inviting bandage film server development
manager for my decks on stage gone great
thank you
hi my name is Ben Litchfield and I've
been working at idec's about 13 years
developing software solutions
specifically in the diagnostic imaging
space our mission at ibex is to improve
the health and well-being of pets people
and livestock what I mean by that is we
sell diagnostic equipment that detects
diseases and pets we sell this equipment
to about 20,000 different veterinary
hospitals worldwide so if you have a cat
or dog that you've brought into the
veterinary practice and had a test run
it's probably been on our equipment we
also do testing in dairy poultry flocks
and other livestock animals we have a
amazing water business where our tests
are used to improve the health of
drinking water for 2 and 1/2 billion
people every single day those tests are
used on all 7 continents in submarines
below the sea and in the international
space station in outer space at idec's
we love our pets and the white cat up
there is my cat nila so we always try to
include them in our presentations that
we do that's a picture of her hanging
out in our cabin in a northern Maine
woods so like I said we our primary
focus is around veterinary diagnostic
equipment and a few years ago we started
to invest heavily in machine learning
technology specifically around imaging
and I want to talk about a few of these
different products that we have the top
left is a set of you device this
analyzes raw urine and takes microscopic
images of the urine and then we use
machine learning to detect elements
within that so that's things like red
blood cells white blood cells and a
variety of different types of crystals
that you can see in urine
we have 250 million images from
veterinary practices in our cloud right
now we're on our fourth major iteration
of our machine learning model the last
model we added the ability to detect a
very rare crystal that we had to use
machine learning to sort of analyze our
data set to find data to
build up our training sets to release
that we have hematology devices we also
have a pathology scanner this generates
about two petabytes of imagery every
single year that we can analyze we have
radiology I'll talk a little bit that
more later we also sell an ECG device we
bundle that with a subscription service
for veterinary practices this is
frequently used for screenings before
surgeries where a lot of cases are sort
of normal hearts they want to know that
the pet is healthy enough to go under
surgery so we use technology to
automatically read those if it's normal
we'll send that result automatically
back to the practice and it's abnormal
will have a cardiologist read it
cardiologists love this feature because
reading normal ECGs all day long is very
boring they want to be able to focus
their efforts on more interesting cases
the other device we sell is a snap kit
these are kids that we sell to sold for
a long time and essentially what they do
is it detectives eases in cats and dogs
things like Lyme disease or heartworm
it's a snap kit because you put some
fluid in their blood serum and then you
snap it and that result takes a few
minutes to show up and it's only valid
for so long so what we did is we
developed this device the snap pro-rider
where the veterinary technician can put
the snap kit in it'll actually
automatically snap it for them set off a
timer and then take a picture of the
window at the right time it reads it
reads the dot on that to see if it's
positive for any of the diseases and
then automatically imports that into our
systems
we have a full suite of radiology
equipment we built we sell both the the
capture equipment once you capture an
image that automatically goes up to our
web PACs cloud system we have 100
million radiographs their most
veterinary practices have an x-ray
capture machine but they don't have a
radiologist on-site so we also provide a
service where practices can send us a
radiograph and we'll have radiologists
read them for them and then finally that
reports and the image will go back into
their practice management software
automatically so I want to drill in a
little bit more into telling us in a
workflow which is where I see a lot of
opportunity and machine learning
technology a typical flow or typical
radiologist will have a couple monitors
on the first monitor they'll have their
their case work list with a list of
other cases they need to work on that
day some of the case details and then an
image viewer on monitors 2 and 3 for
example but one of the things that they
like to do is they were taught to read
x-rays in a certain order so for example
they like to see their thorax images
first and there are abdomen images next
so they spend time the very beginning
organizing all their data generally
about 30 seconds for each case and right
now we're at capacity we have several
hundred radiologists and the only way we
can really expand our business is by
adding more radiologists or making their
workflow more efficient and we've really
hired almost all that generic
radiologists there are already so one of
the challenges is all of our images come
in somewhat unorganized they do have
DICOM tags generally but not always
sometimes they're also wrong and the
veterinary practice the technicians that
capture x-rays are not always highly
trained and it can be a real challenge
sometimes to get a proper x-ray of a pet
on the table
he'll come in upside-down flips
sometimes with a title sometimes that's
blank
so again radiology will spend that 30
seconds or so on every single case just
organizing their images so we spend
over half a million dollars a year
paying radiologist just to organize
their images so the obvious solution is
to use machine learning technology to
help to help them and organize their
data so that when they open up their
case their data is all organized
automatically for them we started
looking to this maybe last year or so
and we started looking at whole image
classification at first so can we take
these images and just bucket them into
high-level pieces of anatomy
for example skull thorax abdomen or
extremity and that works really well it
was very fast and easy to sort of train
whole image classification we didn't
have a lot of data that was labeled so
we kind of just put those all in folders
it was very easy to kind of set up the
training and the labeling of this and
build a model but one of the challenges
we saw was we have a variety of images
like this where it doesn't neatly fit
into any single bucket it's not just a
skull or a thorax or abdomen it really
has components of all those and because
again what our veterinary technicians
aren't highly trained they might take
images like this versus sort of just the
focused Anatomy so this is where the
object detection capability of auto ml
comes in or we can now detect individual
pieces of the anatomy and label them and
know where they are so with this I can
now take this image and say well the
intention of this was a thorax it's
what's in the center of the image
they weren't intending to take a skull
shot it's on the edge of the image so
our first pass of this was actually
before objects detection in auto ml was
available so we hired some temps and
label all this data and built tools to
do all this and in reality that cycle is
very long we built our we built her own
labeling tool we bundled that together
with some tensor flow models we
evaluated that we gave that to some some
interns to label the data and this whole
process was many weeks to months long to
be honest because by the time you get
that labeled data look at it analyze it
go look at which ones were incorrect how
do you know getting good visualization
of
what's wrong and where it's going wrong
without sort of an integrated tool like
object detection is a real challenge so
I want to show this to live a demo of
what we did with object section in Auto
ml so the first part that you do with
all detection auto ml is upload your
data set I'm going to skip this part
today just for time but generally what
you do is just load up your data into
Google Cloud storage
you have the ability to either upload
labels yourself or you can use the
labeling tool within google auto
detection depending on if you already
have labels from another system so for
this example we uploaded 15,000 images
and did about nine different classes so
the classes are over here abdomen
lateral or in BD are sort of two
different angles extremity pelvis
you know skull and whatnot this is what
the labeling looks like so over here is
the skull the thorax cavity the abdomen
and pelvis and if I want to add another
label you simply draw a box it adds a
new entry over here and you pick what
what the label is so it's really fast
and easy to add labels to your system
once you've uploaded your data and you
label all your images the next step is
to train this does take a few hours so
I'm not going to show for this live but
it's pretty simple you just hit train
new model and then hit start training
once your trait once your model has been
trained you then need to go you still
need go through an evaluation phase to
evaluate it what works what didn't work
usually I'll do that by looking at
individual classes you can look at all
of them together but for example if we
look at skull VG's what it shows you
first is your true positives and what's
really nice about this is just the
visualization of this point this piece
integrated into the tool so the green
box is the predicted what the model
predicted and the gray box is what our
ground truth is or what are human labels
labeled that it also shows false
negatives so this is areas where the
model failed to predict the correct
bounding box bounding box detection is a
little bit different than whole image
classification because the bounding box
that you labeled is not going to be
exactly the same as the one the model
predicted you know pixel for pixel so
Google and many other libraries use
what's called intersection over Union
which or essentially how much the two
boxes overlap for that so in this
example these are ones that it's saying
it wasn't really right but in reality
just it just didn't overlap enough you
do have the ability to come in here and
change that threshold so I can I can
lower that a little bit that will raise
our accuracy and sort of change change
of results down here
the other thing I'll show you is the
false positives so where your human
label are said there was some or didn't
say there was something in there but the
model found something and in reality in
our example here this is actually cases
where the human label are missed missed
a label and we need to go fix fix these
labels once you've gone through a couple
cycles of the labeling and training you
automatically get a model deployed it
comes with some sample code which is
simply the rest API or can use curl or
Python or whatever language you want to
use it also has a really simple way to
to test your model on other data so for
example here's uploading an image and
predicting this so that was done sort of
on the fly so the really nice part about
this is all none of these steps required
any code so you don't really need to be
a data scientist or developer to to get
a custom trained model on your own
problem and a model deployed in the
cloud which is really awesome
you've taken sort of what we had before
which is weeks and months of effort lots
of development effort to something that
now maybe a business analyst could even
do we switch back to slides so just to
summarize all now significally
streamlined our process for this again
we went from from weeks down to a couple
days to do this our focus is really not
replacing radiologists but how can we
make them more efficient how can we
streamline their process and make their
work a little bit easier one of the key
pieces I do want to emphasize is trying
to integrate machine learning models
into their existing workflow so as you
think about sort of problems that you
want to solve what are ones that can be
integrated into your workflow and not be
separate if I have to leave the
application that I normally use and go
to somebody else or there's more steps
to be able to utilize that model that
might not be a great use case for
machine learning
and then the other part of this is this
is a simple example but it has a big
impact this is gonna save us half a
million dollars every single year and
there's a product that now really takes
only a couple days because of the
variety of imaging equipment we have at
idec's we really have hundreds of
different types of problems we need to
solve and I'll be tell you know I don't
know is gonna you know make that a lot
easier for us to solve these things cool
I am gonna hand it off now back to
Google
awesome thinks I look Ben for the
awesome use case and our great
partnership together so now we're gonna
have our Amir he's a product lead for
the Comerica team and he's gonna give us
the vision of Google for health creating
the cloud thank you folks
and so I think my colleagues have
presented here how information is
important in healthcare and the value of
information helps make better decisions
so I want to share a little story that
kind of made me brought me into the
cloud healthcare team so as Francesca
mentioned I'm a product manager within
cloud healthcare was the team was in
Google cloud that's focusing on a
industry specific cloud capabilities now
talk a little bit more specific so I
happened to move apartments a couple of
times over the last three years and
every time I move an apartment I like to
find a dentist that lives where I live
like I just like that convenience and
the thing is that when you go to a new
dentist the first thing they want to do
they want to give you a full x-ray mouth
right now so I don't know I don't love
that idea because I'm getting more
radiation the other thing is like I have
to pay for it so I asked the new dentist
is like well why didn't you just connect
to my old dentist because I had my
x-rays there like six months ago and
just like bring the information there
it's like oh I cannot connect we're like
in a different system I was like okay so
I decided before we do the x-ray let me
go to the old dentist and I'll take the
extra on a CD right so I like found
myself he didn't have the CDs I actually
had to find a digital CD apparently they
have this thing medical grade CDs that
cost 20 bucks a pop it's like more
expensive to the cd-rom drive and then I
bring it he burns it on this CD and I
bring the
I knew dr. and says like cannot take it
it's like why not it's like well it's
liability issue maybe somebody tampered
with your pictures and then I I cannot
operate it based on that I can make this
it so it's like okay like so I got the
extra dose of radiation I had to pay for
it because my insurance didn't cover
more than one set of x-rays within six
months but it just made me think of like
how broken the system is in terms of IT
or information flow in the healthcare
space the other little piece I want to
share with you is this article was
written by a medical doctor and also a
PhD in economics by a name of Anupam
Jenna so this gentleman is a Harvard
medical doctor the only reason I
mentioned that he's in PhD in economics
is that we can kind of assume that he
knows how to run design and run an
experiment right and the experiment that
he described in this paper was very
simple so he noticed that in the u.s.
there are 30,000 cardiologists
and once a year 70% of them or 21
thousand other 30,000 go to this
conference it takes a week a week
so basically 70% of arguably a very
important doctor is out of their
hospital not seeing patients question is
what happens to these patients who
thinks that the patients get better
who thinks patients get worse well the
data shows that the patient actually get
better mortality goes down when the
doctors are away and I'm bringing you
can read the details there but it's kind
of like makes you wonder what's going on
here right I have some theories but what
this data suggests that the decisions
that are made in the context of
healthcare systems are not optimized for
necessarily for the benefit of the
patients and this is not the fault of
any specific doctor it's just like the
incentives are complex right there is
the payer there is the providers there
is a patient and sometimes it's not
aligned with the benefit of the people
that should serve so as Google we're
trying to think okay we're definitely
not coming from a place we can oh this
will solve like IT will solve all of
this but I think our strengths is around
organizing information
so we see our team's mission is gonna
organize the world's health care
information and help make better
decisions help our customers and our
partners they make better information
better decisions for health care so what
we do in cloud healthcare we build tools
that help ingest and manage information
for health care which means EHR data
medical imaging data genomics data
dictation data device data and then
enable providers enable vendors enable
our partners and customers to develop
applications on top of this data like
the one that you saw presented by idec's
buyback so in this short talk I want to
give you like a little bit of a
highlight how we are thinking about our
product development roadmap and where we
are thinking of going with this mission
and the one way to slice it would be in
in three layers so the first layer is
the data platform layer and I'll talk a
little bit about this but the idea here
is that before you can use all of these
cool tools like Auto ml like cloud
machine learning engine like big data
analytics which is for example a tool
like bigquery before you can use all of
these tools you need to organize your
data in a way that allows you to use
these tools effectively otherwise as
it's been mentioned like the data comes
and it's kind of an a mess sometimes the
metadata is missing sometimes the
metadata is wrong and it's very
difficult to bring it to a normalized
standard format the other pieces once
your data is in the cloud what can you
do with it like what are the types of
cloud services that you can use so that
you can focus your application of what
really sets you apart and then the last
piece is the actual applications on top
of it so this is like three layers to
think about our platform and I'll go
over in detail each one about about each
one of them so this is kind of a
high-level Buber high-level architecture
slide that describes and how apical
medical imaging can work and in the
context of a cloud so you have some sort
of a device that produces medical images
so on the left here you see something
that resembles an ultra
sound now the data would be ingested
into the cloud through a data layer
platform product we have called cloud
healthcare API and then once the data is
in the cloud it can be normalized it can
be visualized using commercial or open
source viewers and it can be used for
analysis or training of AI models so if
you think about it what happens in a
typical this is an example from medical
imaging world because we're talking
about vision what happens typically the
image is acquired then it's being pre
processed then it's being presented to
the physician that makes the decisions
and then it's being archived so these
are the kind of therefore the different
pieces represented here and the other
piece that related to data is our effort
around public data sets so if you're a
researcher then typically what you're
interested in doing is testing
hypotheses you might have a hypothesis
that I have an algorithm idea to detect
let's say kidney stones I need a way to
test this hypothesis effectively and
then once I test it I want to be able to
commercialize it I want to be able to
integrate it on a clinical workflow so
the first piece for testing hypotheses
we saw that it creates a lot of
bottleneck and it like a lot of
researchers are doing a lot of IT work
instead of doing research so what we
have done we host a set of data sets
that are already public we just simplify
the access to these data sets so if you
have for example a research project
around genomics or medical imaging or
EHR look into our platform you might be
able to find data sets that would help
you simplify the testing of the
hypothesis process once the data is in
the cloud what can you do with it and it
depends really what do you want to do
with it right at the end of the day
cloud is a collection of components and
you can build an application or a
solution that meets your needs some
examples I'll bring from what we see in
the field from talking to customers or
partners and on the analytics to two
buckets in this slide on the left side
you see the analytics use cases on the
right side kind of machine learning
applications so
queries our enterprise data warehouse
tool that can be used in a very
versatile way to analyze huge quantities
of data so petabytes of information I'll
just give you one data point so bigquery
is the tool that is used by Google to
analyze search traffic patterns right so
if you think about the corpus of data
that behind search this is a tool that
can analyze petabyte scale without any
constraints now the way we see people
using this in healthcare varies a lot by
the nature of the application for
example some folks must have flown into
here so you must have you must have seen
in the airport when they ask you hey who
here has flexibility to stay and take a
longer like a later flight we'll give
you let's say a voucher for a hotel you
can see the city now this happens
because the airline's they don't want
they don't like to have empty seats in
the airplane for obvious reasons they
double booked it the problem is you
sometimes in health care find similar
resources that are very high precious
commodity like for example a memoir MRI
machine or even like a special specific
expert write specific specialist you
prefer to overbook and have maybe the
patient wait longer than having a slot
that is not utilized so we see customers
that are using the data that they gather
from different parts of their healthcare
system to try and predict no-shows or
another example I'll give you is
something called procedure leakage
leakage happens when a patient for
example shows up and they do their let's
say about to do a surgery it's a planned
surgery so there is typically a
preoperative imaging they would do this
exploratory make sure that has been
mentioned you want to make sure that the
animal or the human in this case is
capable to undergo the procedure
everything is fine but then if you are
like a large healthcare institution you
see that the patient chose to do the
imaging in your institution but then
they chose to do the surgery somewhere
else and the way that economics of
healthcare work it's actually might be
the imaging procedure you might be doing
at a cost but the surgery procedure is
the one that your hospital actually
makes revenue right so this kind of the
the business side of healthcare
and then that's a problem right because
there's a hospital you need to better
understand like what causes that like
are your surgeons may be providing
different service like do you need to
increase the cost of your imaging like
this is type of business intelligence
that you want to get from the data that
you're collecting from your system so
this is another example of analysis on
large-scale data that you can do the
identification so the the thing I really
liked about like working with medical
images data in the animal space is like
you don't need to worry about pH I so pH
a sense of protector healthcare
information in mind this thing is there
are no HIPAA law for animal pictures
which is fun because you can take
selfies with your patients in the human
world doesn't work that way so you have
to be of course very careful like what
information is shared and collab like in
collaborations for example if you have a
large academic Medical Center typically
you have the clinical entity that these
patients collects the data and then you
have the research part right like these
researchers are trying to increase the
quality of the Newport developed new
procedures developed new operations
develop new diagnostic methods and they
use some of this data from the clinical
side but for this research you have to
be mindful of what data is used so this
the identification process is very
critical to enable research institutions
now the identification is a hard problem
I'll give you an example
every time I present the tools that we
have around the identification I get the
question well can your tool for example
it was a very specific question that I
got until we actually realized where it
came from
can your tool detect a serial number of
a pacemaker and a CT whoa that's like
very specific it turns out it can write
because when you have a pacemaker it has
a unique serial number that serial
number comes in a CT image that scans
the patient and that is used would
identify who that person is right so
that kind of look okay you didn't think
about it but the tool that actually does
work here now the next question was like
can your tool detect a name of a patient
written on a grain of rice in foreign
language that was like worn by on her
necklace so this is the real case they
actually showed me the picture our
didn't work well for this case but so
didn't the human operators or any other
tools right so I'm bringing this example
to mention that it's hard like it's hard
to build tools that are working
perfectly but these tools are evolving
because of the advanced technology and
the AI that's kind of embedded in these
tools so we're making progress and the
benefit of using cloud-based tools is
that they evolve without you having to
deploy automatically and of course there
are some questions around ok so how do
you maintain version controls and we
have some thoughts about that we would
love to share with you as one natural
language processing so this is a huge
umbrella of tools and really depends
what you want to do there and we have
some research efforts in that space and
for example I'll give you a couple of
use cases just to simulate thinking and
imagine a large healthcare provider that
reviews thousands of patients every day
now when a radiologist writes a report
they typically look for the thing that
the patient was referred for like for
example and if the patient was referred
for brain bleed inspection the
radiologist is not looking for cancer
because that's the what the physician
was like telling him hey you should look
for this and in some cases since you
already have the person and you have the
information in front of you might alert
say like hey you you need to look into
this because I wasn't looking for it but
it's it's there in the data so NLP is
something that can be used as well as
image analysis to try and detect these
incidental findings or critical findings
and help organizations implement our
protocols like for example maybe you
looking for brain cancer and you want to
rule that out that doesn't happen but on
the other hand you do see there is like
a bleed that is suspicious that you want
to respond to within a few minutes
because that might be life-threatening
so this is an example where NLP NLP can
play a role to identify what the
radiologist or the doctor writes in
their report and start a new process
inside your IT system labeling so Ben
was talking about the importance of
labeling anytime you want to train any
kind of AI model you need to basically
teach
labeling is the way that you teach
imodels in a supervised learning kind of
environment we have a set of tools that
enables you to label data and and we
also have published some interesting
research on adjudication like if you
think about it let's say you want to
detect kidney stones just for a simple
example so one simplistic approach would
be well have a name like set of images
show these set of images to a
radiologist or someone who can label
them effectively like basically you
could simplistically think like okay I
show this image to one doctor and they
would provide me the labels and that's
good enough in reality what happens if
you do that you bias your model because
you basically encoding the brain of that
one particular doctor so you need to
balance it by offering several opinions
and there is a way to do it in a way
that is cost effective the other example
is think about you have a labeling
budget so let's say you have only 1,000
pictures that you can label but you have
a pool of 10,000 which thousand should
you label they're not all the same right
some of them might have more
discriminatory power so they basically
what it means is that they have more
signal-to-noise so when you're about to
train a model you can get more insight
from this thousand that will that from
the bottom thousand on the machine
learning side of things so Auto ml
obviously and this is a kind of a tool
that allows you very quickly without
writing any code to test out hypotheses
to see how well your model performs some
cases you might be able to use something
like that produced by auto mail right
off the bat in some cases you use it as
an exploratory tool right you kind of
gain some intuition the data scientists
in the audience would know that you have
lots of different tools would and not
depending on the type of job you have
you need to choose the right tool what
we see in practice is that customers are
experimenting with different tools like
Auto ml is kind of initial exploratory
super quick and super easy to try and
understand like the problem and the
dimension that which they should
optimize and sometimes they use
additional tools like loud machine
learning engine which offers you a
little bit more knobs but more control
power but requires
with more expertise on the machine
learning and data science side we are
learning that one of the challenges in
the healthcare space is that a lot of
companies are building AI algorithms and
one of the challenges like how do you is
if let's say if you're a physician a
radiologist for a medical imaging spice
how do you evaluate these models
somebody says that they have a model to
detect the thoracic or skull or
extremity versus another model like how
do you compare their quality right right
now there is no standards for that or
somebody says they have a model to
detect lung nodules for cancer and other
model is doing the same which one is
better so we are building a tool and
that would be allowing you to evaluate
and compare these different models and
choose the right one for you couple of
words and applications we are very much
embracing the open source world and kind
of like we have as Google we have a very
open DNA and we want to enable people to
use the tools that they already use for
used to and we have on the healthcare
space in the medical imaging space and
vision domain we have invested in
integrating some of these tools with our
data back-end so what that means is that
you can take one of these open-source
viewers or you can take a several we
have several commercial viewers through
partners we deliberately chose not to
build our own viewer because we want to
focus on the data platform and the cloud
services that come with it and let their
front end pieces to be driven by the
applications in the market demand
because often times these things tend to
be highly specific for example and I
just learned this morning about a very
specific application in the wound
management niche there is a very
specific viewer very specific workflow
tool and we want to give the tools to
our partners to build for these very
specific solutions because they have the
domain expertise to do that the best
this is an example of open source the
identification tools because of the
reasons I mentioned the identification
is a hard problem to solve but not only
that it's a hard problem to
let's say we have we have a solution
today you can try our di D solution one
question you might ask us like well how
good do your solution right now can you
give me some specifications the
challenge with that is that in order to
give you specifications we need to agree
on a data set and the data set has to
have thi in a protected health
information now for this the Nate's the
sensitive data you cannot have a
publicly facing data set with pH I so
that the approach we took is we
integrated existing open source tools
with our data back-end and we offered
these tools as well as our own tool to
our users and customers and partners
basically to test it out on your data
set so the idea is like here are three
tools two of them are open source one of
them is ours
see what works best we're learning in
practice that people are actually trying
to do like belt and suspenders kind of
approach so they might do actually all
three in chain for four because they
they might be used to some of these
tools from the past sometimes there is
an issue of compliance because the tool
that open-source tools they have been
approved by their regulatory group
inside sometimes our tool needs takes to
longer to get approved so they basically
want to increase the level of confidence
they have in TIG solution so this is
like a couple of slides just to show you
an example of a what we call a model
browser or model Explorer this is just a
mock at this point this will be
available around mid year and this is a
tool that would allow you to select an
AI model to select a data set and apply
the AI model on a data set and be able
to compare or evaluate or reason about
the results so for example think about
you could take an AI model you could
feed it a data set and you can generate
an AUC curve like the ones you've seen
before for auto ml we also publish the
set of tutorials that teach you how to
essentially how to build your own AI
models on top of medical imaging data
and we have one that focuses on auto ml
is a tool we have one if you want a
little
flexibility focused on cloud machine
learning engine again the right tool for
the job is is the name of the game here
so this is the link where you can find
it and it also the example we chose to
highlight in this case very simple and
not really of clinical use but it
touches through all the stations that
you would need in order to develop a
real application so the example here
uses a public data set that for
mammography and it basically creates a
classifier for breast density you can
see these screenshots from auto ml work
so this basically allows you to evaluate
the results and tune your model you can
see like hey my models not good enough I
need to get more data like a question we
often get is like how much data do I
need in order to train a good model and
it's an empirical question right because
if your data as I mentioned before has a
strong signal to noise ratio you might
need less data but if you keep feeding
it examples that are the same then
obviously you need much more of that so
the rule of thumb here and Francisco
maybe keep me honest what we're hearing
in the medical imaging space is that for
each class you're trying to classify
this between a thousand and ten thousand
samples kind of a good starting point so
the advantage of deep learning is that
it reduces the need for you to do
feature engineering but it comes at the
expense of having to produce more data
in a world where we produce more data
than what we ever knew what to do with
before I think it can be good news the
other way we're trying to optimize it
how do we help you use your labeling
budget more effectively once you develop
the model how do you deploy it in the
clinical workflow so this is another
piece like how do you take the output of
your AI predictions and bring it to the
surface so that your physician can make
use of it we have some sample
architectures about that come talk to us
in this event you see
[Music]